michael saylor was the very first public
company ceo to take his company
microstrategy and put bitcoin on the
balance sheet that was the shot heard
round the world once michael saylor
started to put bitcoin on the balance
sheet of microstrategy every other
public company ceo and cfo had to come
up with a bitcoin strategy now michael
saylor over the last two years continues
to push forward and add more and more
bitcoin just this morning he announced
that he has purchased another 190
million dollars of bitcoin it's about 4
167 bitcoin at a price of 45
714
that means that microstrategy now holds
129 000 bitcoin that they have acquired
for about 3.9 billion dollars that is
incredible to see a public company ceo
and a company that just two years ago
had zero bitcoin now holds almost 130
000 bitcoin this is going to go down as
either the greatest wall street trade in
history or it will be a complete
disaster i tend to think that it'll be
the former if we go ahead and we take a
look michael saylor isn't just doing
this with shareholder capital though he
really believes michael saylor also took
a 205 million dollar loan against some
of that bitcoin collateral from
silvergate bank and is using some of
those proceeds to go ahead and buy this
190 million dollars worth of bitcoin on
top of that sailor also owns a very big
personal stake in bitcoin as well he has
about 17 732 bitcoin that would be worth
about 833 million dollars today off a
cost base of about 175 million dollars
and so regardless of whether it's
michael saylor personally whether it's
microstrategy the business intelligence
firm that he's been running for over 20
years or it's a pleb sitting at home
michael's got a great piece of advice
the best time to hold bitcoin is forever
and ultimately that's exactly how to
think about a digital decentralized
currency in a world of undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy michael
saylor is leading the way and
microstrategy is one of the largest
holders of bitcoin in the world i can't
wait to see just how many bitcoin
they're going to be able to acquire if
they keep focused and they continue to
execute this treasury strategy hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time